today's video is sponsored by nordvpn
give yourself options online go to
nordvpn.com forward slash bio to get a
two year plan at a huge discount plus a
free gift more on them in a bit
when the beatles first landed in the u.s
a guy who knew one or two things about
music was unimpressed predicting their
metaphorical death that guy was frank
sinatra who would later change his mind
and even cover their songs his favorite
track was something from the abbey road
album before performing the song he
would introduce it as his favorite
lennon mccartney song good choice frank
the only problem is that something had
been written and composed by george
harrison the band's lead guitarist this
anecdote best captures the career and
legacy of george harrison known as the
choir beetle his musical contribution
was often overlooked fading in the
shadow cast by those songwriting giants
john lennon and paul mccartney but as
we'll learn in today's episode george
was far from being a wall flower and his
musical talent was on par with the
greatest stars of the 1960s and 1970s
musical scene
[Music]
george harrison was born on february 23
1943 in liverpool northern england he
was the youngest of four children born
to harold a bus driver and trade union
official under louise a grocery store
clerk george's childhood was relatively
peaceful and stable but the harrisons
were not by any means wealthy and their
house in liverpool was small cramped and
terribly cold george's parents signed
him up at dovedale primary school the
same one attended by john lennon but
george was three years his junior and
the two never met there another dovedale
schoolmate remembered george as being a
choir guy who nonetheless possessed a
great sense of humor and liked to cause
mischief more importantly he had a
strong moral compass defending
schoolmates against bullies in 1949 the
harrisons moved to speak southeast of
liverpool george continued with his
studies winning a place at the
prestigious liverpool institute in 1954
but young george did not fit him well in
this new environment in plain terms he
was dead bored an intense love for
popular music had swept away any
interest in academics as teachers
lectured away the skinny teenager filled
his notebooks with drawings of guitars
and lyrics from his favorite elvis
presley songs george's musical epiphany
happened at the age of 13. while cycling
around his neighborhood he had
heartbreak hotel by elves drifting from
an open window it hit him like a
double-decker bus he knew what he wanted
to be in life he wanted to be a
guitarist the young harrison started
dressing up as a teddy boy sporting
drainpipe trousers and a quiff he
listened avidly to chuck berry and buddy
holly as well as the early all-british
skiffle records for the uninitiated
skiffle is a sub-genre of american folk
music often played with rudimentary and
improvised instruments after a surge in
popularity in the 1920s skiffle enjoyed
a revival in britain in the 1950s george
wanted rock or skiffle or both and to do
that he needed money encouragement and
well a guitar he received all three from
his parents especially louise who
part-time to the ballroom dancing
instructor and was happy to indulge
george's musical inclination and so the
harrisons bought george's first guitar
for three pounds not a small sum in
times of post-war rationing he taught
himself the first chords and his
six-string beauty became his entire
world in harrison's own words when i was
a kid growing up the guitar was the main
thing that saved me from borden it was
the only job i could think of that i
wanted to do playing guitar and being in
a rock band eventually george graduated
from the liverpool institute with only
one o level in art rather than
continuing his studies he apprenticed as
an electrician but attendance to the
liverpool institute had one positive
consequence while riding the bus back
from school george befriended an older
schoolmate who he described as an
upperclassman that posh boy was none
other than paul mccartney paul's first
impressions of george were of a cocky
little guy with a good sense of himself
he
wasn't cowed by anything
by the time george and paul had become
friends the former had started taking
his first steps in showbiz george and
his brother peter had formed a band
johnny and the rebels their debut gig
was at the british legion club and speak
they had prepared just two songs because
it was meant to be an audition but when
the main band failed to show up they
were asked to perform they played those
two songs over and over and returned
home with bellies full of ale and
pockets stuffed with ten shillings each
meanwhile the foundations of the beatles
were being laid in july 1957 paul
mccartney joined the quarryman john
lennon skiffleband in february of 1958
the group needed a new guitarist a ball
suggested that they auditioned george
lennon was not thrilled as he didn't
want a 14 year old kid in his band but
he agreed to give him a chance and an
audition was organized three future
beatles met on the top floor of a double
decker bus and john asked the newbie to
play raunchy by bill justice when george
launched into the twangy lead guitar if
jon gave his approval but lennon later
admitted that he didn't care much for
george at the beginning i couldn't be
bothered with him when he first came
around it took me years to come around
to him to star considering him as an
equal shortly after the audition the
quarrymen abandoned skiffle for the more
promising rock and roll genre wise move
as the combo was booked for a series of
local gigs throughout 1959 in may 1960
the band changed its name to the silver
beatles and launched a two-week tour in
scotland that summer the band was joined
by drummer pete best they were now a
quintet in addition to best there was
george john paul and the original
bassist stuart sutcliffe the silver
beetles were gaining in confidence and
skill so much so that their agent allen
williams organized residency at two
clubs in hamburg germany the indra and
the kaiserkeller george played his first
german gig on august 17th 1960. by then
the band had dropped the silver from
their name and alter the spelling to
beetles with an a instead of beetles
with a double e this was a homage to the
beat generation harrison and the guys
played for eight hours straight on stage
for two pounds and fifty pence a day not
a fortune but aged only 17 george was
earning more than his parents and there
was another priceless reward the crowds
of rowdy yet adoring teenagers mostly
girls soon the beatles developed a
reputation for rocking the brains out of
their audiences clearly outclassing
every other band imported from britain
george knew it mocking rival musicians
as being crummy he only had words of
appreciation for the drummer of rory
storm and the hurricanes though one
richard starkly a here ringo starr
george gained confidence also in another
aspect of rock and roll life getting on
with the ladies it was in hamburg that
he lost his virginity the other beatles
were in the room pretending to ignore
him but could not help themselves from
applauding at the end so rock and roll
check sex check what was missing
drugs of course to keep up with the
demands of the kaiser keller club george
started taking prescription stimulants
which would cause him to froth at the
mouth and to hallucinate the time spent
in hamburg was also a time of cultural
growth for george due to his young age
he became a sort of mascot for a group
of young intellectuals including art
student astrid kersha thanks to their
influence the beatles honed their image
ditching teddy boy quiffs for a look
inspired by parisian existentialists and
with that the beatles haircut was born
something else far deeper was born in
hamburg though the power dynamics within
the band lennon mccartney already
started competing for preeminence within
the band a duel fought with lyrics and
melodies as weapons of choice harrison
still a junior member was relegated to
the backseat but from there he observed
listened and learned and he developed
his signature lead guitar style one that
eschewed fretboard gymnastics preferring
carefully crafted riffs and short solos
in which every single note had a purpose
and every lick had a story but this
early adventure was doomed to be
short-lived in october 1960 the beatles
were booked by a new club the top ten
their kaiser keller promoter bruno
cosmeter was furious for this betrayal
and he got revenge he snitched the
police that harrison was still a miner
resulting in his expulsion mccartney and
best retaliated by setting a condom on
fire in one of koschmeider's venues
which resulted in their expulsion as
well by december 1960 the beatles were
reunited in liverpool performing at the
legendary cavern club amongst the
screaming sweaty teenagers that one
proud mum mrs harrison singing along
with the other fans the apple of her eye
could not stay 17 forever though in
april of 1961 once george had turned 18
the band returned to hamburg now quick
question for you how many times have you
been on the internet and noticed creepy
ads that seem to be following you around
and tailored to your search history or
speaking of search history how many
times you've been worried that somebody
maybe even your government is tracking
the websites that you visit well
fortunately for you today's video is
sponsored by nordvpn which is helping to
give internet users all the tricks and
tools of a proper 21st century online
experience now you may have heard me
talk about what nordvpn could do for you
previously encrypt your internet data
move your activity to another location
with just one click either for superior
security or more streaming options and
all that's still true nordvpn has more
than 5000 servers in 60 countries but
vpns give you access to so many more
options than just new tv shows even
though that is fantastic having trouble
connecting to social media we live
nordvpn want to buy a movie that's
cheaper somewhere else or maybe not even
available in your country nor vpn want
to route your connection through
multiple servers just for double layered
protection yeah nordvpn does it with
nordvpn you can access it all and that
includes utilizing their threat
protection upgrade which blocks ads
eradicates web trackers checks for
malware and more right now as part of a
special deal you guys can get a two-year
plan at a huge discount plus an
additional bonus gift on top of that and
if you try nord and change your mind
they offer a 30-day money-back guarantee
all you got to do is go to nordvpn.com
bio again that's nordvpn.com bio for a
two-year deal at a huge discount plus a
free bonus gift on top of that or just
follow the link below and now back to
today's video
[Music]
in june they had their chance to record
their first single my bonnie which
attracted the attention of liverpudlian
record shop owner brian epstein the band
was invited back to their hometown by
epstein in the meanwhile sutcliffe had
decided to leave the band to marry his
early news astrid kershaw paul to combat
said epstein took them under his wing in
november 1961 paving the way for the big
break of the beatles in february 1962
bryan sent an audition tape to major
record label decca which was famously
rejected it was a hard blow for the band
but lennon later recalled how it was
george who kept everybody's spirits up
luckily they listened to him and they
persevered another demo tape was well
received by parlophone and offshore to
bmi in may 1962 the band signed a record
deal and in june they started their
first recording sessions during these
early sessions they were assigned to
paraphone producer george martin and he
asked them let me know if there's
anything you don't like george harrison
replied well for a start i don't like
your tie the two georges did not get on
well but one thing they did agree on was
pete best was not the right drama for
the beatles when martin raised the issue
with the other band members harrison
enthusiastically suggested they hire his
old pal from hamburg ringo starr
sometime in early september a large
beetle fan showed up backstage at the
cabin club and asked where pete best was
harrison replied oh we sacked him to
which the fan socked him in the eye and
just left george's black eye can be seen
on a september 1962 cover of the
magazine mersey beat in october 1962 the
beatles released their first successful
single love me do before long
beetlemania had started and the nation
to embrace it most enthusiastically
would be the us
the fab four from liverpool started
their tour across the atlantic in
february 1964 leaving a profound mark
since appearing on the ed sullivan show
on that occasion george was suffering
from flu which almost prevented him from
playing and made it difficult for him to
speak at all pence the press and the
public immediately dubbed him the quiet
beetle which wasn't exactly true but it
matched his serious dark persona and his
growing dislike for the excesses of
beetlemania he was in it for the music
and he soon grew tired of the constant
barrage of unwanted public attention and
hysterically screaming fans his sense of
frustration was made worse by still
being considered a junior partner when
it came to songwriting producer george
martin always gave precedence to the
compositions by john and paul but
harrison was undeterred his first solo
writing credit with the beatles was
don't bother me written in august
harrison's contribution to the beatles
sound however was not limited to penning
songs he also enriched his bandmate's
compositions with carefully crafted
rifts and solos and he expanded the
sonic palette of their productions by
introducing new instruments and
equipment for example in 1964 he picked
up the rear camera 12-string guitar and
later introduced the beatles sound the
moog and arp synthesizers but the
instrument which became the trademark of
the harrison sound was the sitar the
stringed instrument central to indian
traditional music george had first
picked it up while shooting the film
help but he only started formal training
on the instrument after meeting sitava
virtuoso ravi shankar in june of 1966.
george had been married since january
1966 with british model patty boyd who
encouraged him to expand his interest in
indian culture beyond the musical realm
and into a spiritual quest harrison
started studying yoga and meditation
attended lectures and visited india in
september of 1966. by august of the
following year george had converted the
other three beetles to the practice of
transcendental meditation popularized by
the guru maharishi mahashiyogi in
february of 1968 the band traveled to
rishikesh in india where they spent
several weeks of study and meditation
with the maharishi himself ringo and
paul left the retreat early but lennon
and harrison remained until april that's
when a scandal erupted with allegations
that the maharishi had made improper
sexual advances towards actress mia
farrow john and george left rishikesh
and in june the band made a statement
distancing themselves from their guru
george however would later cast doubts
on the allegations and continue to
support and fund his movement
it could be argued that george
harrison's interest in indian music and
culture was almost entirely responsible
for their influence on the
counter-culture movement of the 1960s
and his spiritual activism may have
inspired in turn john lennon's own
activism the indian and eastern
influences however can be clearly
appreciated on harrison's musical
development for example the lyrics of
while my guitar generally weeps were
inspired by the chinese classic book of
changes or e ching and what is perhaps
harrison's most famous song here comes
the sun features unusual time signatures
such as 11 8 and 7 8 these were borrowed
from traditional indian music at the
same time george was developing a
musical life outside of the confines of
the fab four forging friendships with
legends bob dylan and eric clapton
clapton collaborated with george on his
first solo album wonder war music of
1968 inspired by indian music and blues
rock this record was followed by a
radical change in direction 1969's
electronic sound and atmospheric and
sometimes disturbing avant-garde piece
entirely performed on a moog three-piece
synthesizer so all fine and dandy on the
solo music production but the home front
was not going well george was a man of
contrasts and in this period they were
particularly exaggerated at times he
plunged into ascetic meditation fueled
by an increasingly dogmatic spiritual
outlook other times he liked to party
hard and indulge in drugs especially lsd
and cannabis on march 12 1969 harrison's
house was raided by the police and the
guitarist was charged with legal
possession of weed all the while george
and his wife patty one successfully
trying to conceive a child the
accumulating tensions led to the
deterioration of their marriage which
progressed in parallel with the gradual
dissolution of the beatles during the
last two years of activity of the band
1969 and 1970 harrison frequently
clashed with lennon mccartney as usual
george's compositions were overlooked or
modified by john and paul harrison
retaliated by pointing out that since
yoko owner had entered the picture
lennon's creative juices had just dried
up harris invented his frustrations in a
new song wawa which made it clear how
the lennon mccartney duo didn't hear him
sighing a reference to his music and
spiritual contributions wawa didn't make
it to any of the last two beatles albums
abbey road and let it be it instead
enriched the vast catalogue of
unpublished harrison tunes which would
soon see the light of day
[Music]
in april 1970 the beatles announced
their split music fans worldwide mourned
but george was ready to go solo in
november he released his third album all
things must pass this triple lp contains
the popular track my sweet lord which
unfortunately was at the center of a
lawsuit in february 1971 label breitun's
music sued harrison as the song was too
similar to he's so fine by the chiffons
but the album contains more than 100
minutes of damn fine tunes and look out
harrison's first use of the slide guitar
which would become a signature technique
most of the album had been composed at
george's new lavish residence friar parr
an extravagant neo-gothic mansion in
henley on thames oxfordshire george
loved spending weeks of solitude and
relaxation behind its walls tending to
the vast gardens always a matter of
contrast george could spend a fortune on
a new home but at the same time dedicate
great energy to alleviate the plight of
the poor and the desperate in august of
1971 with the help of ravi shankar bob
dylan and ringo starr he organized two
charity concerts in new york collecting
aid for the victims of floods in
bangladesh the events would set the
template for future rock charity
concerts think of things like live aid
professional success was counterpointed
by further personal misery however his
relationship with patty took a huge hit
in 1974 when she left him for his good
friend eric clapton but harrison did not
really have the moral high ground he had
been having several affairs including
one with ringo starr's wife maureen in
that same year george undertook a tour
in north america with rabbi shankar
harrison disappointed fans by refusing
to play any beatles songs while starting
to feel the strain of life on the road
the tour was a failure but it had a
silver lining while preparing it george
met olivia trinidad arias a marketing
manager with a m records olivia captured
george's interest thanks to a shared
interest in meditation moreover she was
able to exert positive influence on
harrison curbing his excessive
consumption of alcohol and drugs when
george and patty boyd eventually
divorced in 1977 he was ready to fully
embrace a new life with olivia on august
1st 1978 they welcomed their baby boy
donnie and one month later they married
at henley's registry office george was
at his happiest when he could just chill
with his family and spend long hours
gardening in his friar park estate so
much so that dani as a little boy had no
idea that his father was a world famous
rock star he recalled i was pretty sure
he was just a gardener besides gardening
george expanded his endeavors into other
forms of artistic expression in 1979 he
co-founded movie production company
handmade films it was thanks to handmade
that monty python could produce life of
brian a religious satire which no other
company dared funding harrison and
handmade produced other successes like
time bandits the long good friday and
with neil and i but harrison also
bankrolled stinkers like shanghai
surprise one of several wrong decisions
which eventually bankrupted handmade
films in 1980 george also picked up the
typewriter authoring his autobiography i
me mine in it he avoided any mention of
john lennon to which the former beatle
took great offense harrison tried to
contact him to resolve their issues but
fate got in the way in the shape of a
gunman mark david chapman who shot
lennon on december 8th 1980. now the
beatles were truly history
[Music]
george continued to compose throughout
the 1980s releasing two solo albums one
compilation and two records with a super
group of super musical friends the
traveling wilburys the band was founded
in april 1988 as brainchild of harrison
and jeff lynne of electric light
orchestra the duo recruited three
musicians which you may have heard of
roy orbison tom petty and bob dylan the
woolburys were anything but traveling as
they never went on tour but their
success encouraged george to organize
his last ever set of gigs despite the
boyd clapton affair the two guitarist
friends had never fallen out and they
decided to tour japan in 1991 and 1992.
this would be the last time that george
performed in public his health had
already started to deteriorate and in
1997 he was diagnosed with throat cancer
as a result of a life of excesses and
heavy smoking the initial treatment was
successful but it would be a short-lived
respite in the early hours of december
30th 1999 michael abram a paranoid
schizophrenic managed to sneak into fire
park armed with a kitchen knife harrison
tackled the intruder but abram fought
him off and stabbed him 40 times
puncturing one of his lungs luckily
olivia intervened knocking out the
would-be killer with a table lamp
harrison recovered quickly from the
attack quicking that abram certainly
wasn't auditioning for the traveling
wilburys but according to olivia the
wounds only contributed to george's
declining health in fact his cancer
returned this time affecting his lungs
and later his brain after further
treatment in switzerland and the united
states george harrison died in los
angeles on november 29 2001. his spirits
were up until the very end shortly
before his death he was cracking jokes
with his old power ringo star according
to george's wishes his ashes were
dispersed in the river ganges at the
peak of his artistic activity with the
beatles george harrison may have
struggled to have his voice heard but he
was successful in steadily building a
legacy of profound inspiring music
spanning at least four different genres
ten years after his death donnie
harrison returned to friar park and
noted how the garden had never looked
better the trees planted by his father
had finally grown he remarked you don't
build a garden for yourself right now
you build a garden for future
generations my father definitely had a
long view
you